how's it going everybody we have really
been treated today we have several
Avengers for leaks
earlier today I did a video on a leaked
photo of Thanos new sword that he'll use
an Avengers for and just recently it
just happened we got two more new photos
of weapons that will appear in Avengers
4 thanks to Marvel news India don't
forget about my giveaway I'm giving away
a copy of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray some special edition posters and
memorabilia so be sure to subscribe like
and comment below with your thoughts so
you can enter ok so the first one is
Stormbreaker nothing new here in fact it
still has groots branches as the handle
but this is the most detailed photo that
we've ever seen up Stormbreaker and it
looks really cool
just like the photos of thanasis sword
the blade on the axe looks a little
dinged up you can see some chips and
some scratches on it and I'm sure we're
gonna see a lot more of it and Avengers
4 ok now for this mysterious weapon it
is definitely nothing that we've seen in
the MCU there are lots of questions
surrounding this new mysterious weapons
for starters has this already been made
was this made before the events of
infinity war or perhaps maybe III made
this after Thor visited him cuz this
definitely looks Asgardian and if you
take a look at the handle you can see
that it looks exactly like mule near for
a little bit I thought maybe this is
some old Asgardian weapon maybe Bor used
it Thor's grandfather he was originally
supposed to have a scene in Avengers
Infinity Ward that they never did so
maybe they would do it in Avengers 4 but
while doing some research I actually
stumbled upon this picture of black
dwarf if you take away the handle the
double blades and the point on top look
exactly the same even the two points on
each side of the blade are exactly the
same so one of a few things are
happening here one is that this could be
old concept art they could have
originally planned for a black dwarf to
wield this weapon in the movie but just
went a different route that would also
explain why there's basically the same
picture of Stormbreaker in the same
style such as this one because they're
from before infinity war
two black dwarf could come back somehow
we know time travel is involved in
Avengers 4 so maybe he wields the weapon
then three Thanos wields it somehow or
four it's Asgardian and either Thor
makes it or he gets it from an ancestor
they're all plausible and unfortunately
I think it's probably old concept art it
looks way too much like the black dwarfs
axe but they could retcon it into MCU
and make it for a completely different
purpose and maybe Thor wields it in
Avengers 4 let me know your thoughts on
this and if you have an idea of what you
think it could be let me know leave your
thoughts in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe like and comment
with your favorite superhero so you can
enter my giveaway as always thank you so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]